I was walking around looking at just
anything that caught my eye and everyone
knows Monaco people it's like for the
people anyway so they were showing it
off it turns out right next to it they
were showing off lead over fire but it's
in the same style I love how they do
this known for kind of taking
complicated game mechanics and reducing
them down to like one or two button type
sure simplifying the crap out of them
that's pretty with Monaco is like a
complicated ice game made simple and
forensic and rocks that's exactly right
it's kind of like this realtime strategy
RTS style like Starcraft but he reduced
it to two buttons it's the same thing
where you have to start building your
foundation but this one you're
slaughtering pigs to get products then
you can start raising units units are
ridiculous there you start out with like
rap you can move on to flying donkeys
and you're attacking the other person's
base to ultimately defeat them alright
well I also saw an animal themed game
called berserkers come on it's a
competitive local action game where four
players play armadillos of course things
armadillos
map and these maps are kind of laid out
in such a way where they encourage like
kind of like continuous looping around
through like common like choke points
and that kind of thing the twist here is
that you're all trying to run away from
a murderous and the bear you're all
rolling around and your basic ability is
as armadillos you can kind of like it
big this little trench in the ground
that creates this kind of like dirt wall
that actually blocks off these other
players so when two of you are trying to
run away from a bear and the other
players a little bit farther behind you
can seal him off at a choke point and
he's stuck and the bear comes and
devours him and he loses a life so the
whole thing is just about like finding
like these movement patterns throughout
the map and just trying to sabotage
other players this is really a show for
the people it's about seeing things
might not have ever seen before weird
experiences and I had a hell of a weird
experience take a game unlike any other
it was called sound self Robin are no is
kind of known for making these pretty
whimsical style games that are supposed
to make you look internally and think
about life deep stuff it's hard to do
that haha bear with me here okay okay
farewell I get it yeah bear with me in
topical so and I lay down on a
sub-woofer on my back I put a device
around my neck decade the my vocal cords
and oculus on my eye eyes and then a
headphones my voice was changing the
dynamics and telling me to chant to kind
of influence the sounds and sights that
were happening to me all based on my
tone and inflections of my voice I asked
him what kind of reactions he's been
getting from people and he said most of
the time people don't know how to react
because they're so I blown away by this
weird experience they're really not sure
what to say he's actually had people
come out of it crying he's had people
coming out of it excited and were like
super zenned out and it's it was a
unlike anything else that I've ever
experienced like very interesting visual
colors with a unique experience for me
and I think that something cool that
most people probably don't ever get to
run yeah I mean that's one thing that I
really like about the indi- is that you
can find those weird off-kilter offbeat
games like I found one called the Magic
Circle it is a video game about making
video games okay which is already super
meta and so this game is actually about
like this legendary vaporware product
that's just like exists in the ether and
has just never been finished and you you
get into it and you're a player in this
world and you actually like here
dialogue between two different
developers working on it and their
constant constantly bickering with each
other suddenly out of nowhere this voice
appears who tells you you know what this
is a great opportunity you need to take
advantage of this situation you can
actually finish this game or just
sabotage it if you want to doesn't
matter it's up to you it's a world
that's ready to be exploited so that
manifests itself in very
weighs like any object in the game you
can actually like freeze it and then
like jump into it's AI profile and
actually like swap out its different
kind of like alliances and abilities and
things like that so like one thing I did
in the game was take these like little
dog creatures that start attacking you
instantly jump in turn them friendly
make them my pals and then maybe on one
or two of them I remove their ability to
walk took that kind of brown
transportation profile pocketed it went
to a mushroom gave it the ability to
walk and suddenly I have like a small
army of dogs and mushrooms to do my
bidding but that's just like a really
small part of it like you actually use
this stuff to solve really complex
environmental puzzles so it all builds
up in relation ways and I was talking to
the guys and they says that like it's
still very possible for players to break
the game but that's also kind of a fun
for them is that also possibly a way to
pin you can sabotage the game by
breaking he told me it's a game where
you can either finish it or you can
cancel the game so I feel like there are
different pathways you can take but once
you actually sit down and play it and it
all kind of starts to click you realize
this game is really cool and it's doing
something totally crazy I don't know if
it has any mass-market appeal because
it's so meta and inside baseball but I
had a blast play that's awesome it seems
like that is a theme here at PAX I've
seen a lot of games that are in there
like infant stages they're not ready yet
yeah I'm shocked they're even showing
some of them because they're like very
early art stage but it's about the
experience and just enjoying the game
and you're right a lot of these games
might not ever be in stores but it's
about that true packs experience of
trying something new and getting getting
a really good story out of it